I'm gonna be making the ultimate vegan
ice cream it's gonna be the best vanilla
vegan ice cream you've ever had was this
wrong this is very weird I don't know
it's like when you walk into Home Depot
you want to give the people with
[Music]
[Music]
I'm gonna try these two methods that
I've been researching so the first one
I'm gonna be using frozen bananas got
these bad boys frozen solid
ok it just looks like a weird old finger
I was rushing ok nobody wants this in
there I'm gonna reach out of a closet
and get you while we're waiting for
those to freeze I'm gonna try my second
method which is with coconut milk oh
here I mean don't provoke me okay we're
gonna get there Vaughn smooth not a
chunk in sight okay so we've got these
frozen peels with pre peeled bananas
that I need oh yeah love that sound
oh that's nice actually I'm gonna go
freeze this and that we can go check on
these two bad boys tomorrow
[Music]
that's not that's not the sound you want
to hear I can chew it
tastes like a banana what would you say
is like our frame of reference for vegan
ice cream fam Lewis really delicious but
do you think they like give us tips
should we go to bed Lewin yeah let's
just do it okay so we called van Lowe
and ice cream and it turns out the
founder of the company and van Luwan is
gonna be working today so we're gonna go
get some tips and tricks from him I
cannot believe this is happening
all right here we go I need to make the
ultimate vanilla vegan ice cream okay
cool would you give me a tips on kind of
how to like bring out the vanilla flavor
but to not let the like coconut
overpower so we think the best way to
make vegan ice cream now is using
coconut cream cashew milk cocoa butter
and coconut oil so each of those things
plays a different role in creating a
super luscious chewy creamy vegan ice
cream it's a good meal other than the
sugar sweetly healthy I was gonna ask
you can my cat eat this because
sometimes she licks my ice cream today
I'm feeling a lot more confident because
I got to talk to Ben freakin Van Leeuwen
and now I'm gonna show you some of the
things that I learned so the first thing
we're gonna do is take these cashews
that I soaked it overnight and we're
gonna make cashew milk so I'm gonna try
to gracefully dump this in here I don't
know if that's even humanly possible but
Oh honestly not so bad
is that good oh wow
that looks so good whoa this is thick
how many C's and get warrants three okay
so now we're going to put the coconut
milk in with the cashier oh shoot cups
now it's time to sauce it up I'm gonna
make simple syrup so that's just some
water and some sugar let's mix that baby
up
we should DM then why what a scream it's
finally nothing I am also melting the
cocoa butter I'm pretty sure it's gonna
help it stay fairly solid well the
coconut oil should give it that melty
nuts that we want in an ice cream we
don't want to be rock solid like the
coconut nightmare we saw yesterday Oh
now's the time where you can add the
flavor that you want now that you have
the base I'm gonna use actual vanilla
bean because work fancy schmancy around
here so now we're gonna take this and
we're going to chill it for like an hour
to you're supposed to freeze this for 24
hours are you kidding
don't put that thing in the freezer
right now it's so great I'm sorry all
right I'm gonna get the compressor we're
gonna test out our first batch of its
that just a press start oh my god we
might have actual hope here guys oh my
god I think I actually did something
right today look at that and we haven't
even frozen it yet oh my god no I got it
here we go Oh get out of there you Wow
I'm like very impressed with us that is
beautiful oh mama that's like no yeah
yeah now I'm gonna freeze this because I
mean we gotta eat it and then tomorrow
we're gonna try to perfect the flavor if
you've got the consistency down but now
we want to get that delicious vanilla
flavoring and try to lose the undertones
of coconut
so my plan is to kind of balance the
fats out a little bit more I'm gonna he
is blessed coconut oil I'm gonna he does
more cocoa butter so it has lots of
coconut flavor so that's basically what
we're gonna be working with of this
batch now I have that batch with Doug
I'm gonna let it turn for an hour and
meantime I'm gonna test another recipe
I'm just playing with the levels of
cashew milk and coconut milk so we've
got ice cream flying all over the place
right now it's basically not say I had
like a bad breath after ting I don't
love it paper kind of thing flavor is
very odd I don't know what to do wait
clear this fire police well paint this
and be mean but then be nice and tell me
in the textures good
[Music]
I know you guys have been working really
hard on this but
this is very weird so okay so what this
is is you need a lot more a lot more
vanilla yeah one I don't think one beans
as strong I think that we can up to
vanilla just to kind of overpower that
flavor I'm scared
would inflate oh okay we have been
asking for help and people keep telling
us it doesn't taste good but nobody
knows how to fix it I don't know what to
do
I want to keep testing 30 Friday and
we've been shooting this since Monday
and also we're running out of resources
and this isn't a game of Thrones budget
so if we can't afford to keep buying
stuff okay
no I'm just frustrated because I just
want it to be something that I'm proud
of and I'm not proud of what we have so
far
I'm not getting so desperate I almost
feel like we should DM Ben and ask him
for help like Ben Van Leeuwen yeah demon
you should seriously be able I feel like
a maniac doing this hey Ben I'm so sorry
to bother you but we're having an
ice-cream crisis am I actually sending
this
and now I'm just leasing you're watching
it this is turning into a reality TV
show
whoa look at that faithful that's sorry
I'm so annoyed right now it just tastes
like wood and licorice the texture is
good and now I just want to cry the
amount of times okay well I'm gonna make
it work
so this cocoa butter taste it yeah
actually I didn't even taste it
Oh slow weird looks like piss like when
you walk into Home Depot you snow the
weird like wood and the patter it's so
bad this is what I would that is the
weird close your eyes and walk into Home
Depot
that's hack me and call me Sally if that
is one of you I'm gonna take it down for
six tablespoons of cocoa butter to four
and I'm gonna bring up to the coconut
oil from two tablespoons Deportes
they're gonna add in the coconut milk
and the cashew milk and then we're going
to emulsify I'm going to actually start
the blender with these in it already and
then I'm going to slowly pour in the
sugar water mixture to make sure that
they really blend together and mold
safai
sounds like a great spell I'll be
cutting around that I'm gonna go chill
this and I'm gonna chill and then we're
gonna churn it and call it a day mama
would knock on whatever you have nearby
over
[Music]
we don't want to overturn it okay I'm
gonna turn it off should we take a
little teeny taster
[Music]
that is so much better you're about to
spring to the heavens oh my gosh good I
think we figured it out oh my god I'm so
happy this feels like victory whoa mama
whoa we are done I'm ready to wrap this
puppy up let's get some people on here
to try it this is a very important taste
tester because Rachel's vegan it's gonna
be some a Gordon Ramsay review right
here I contacted everything no pressure
[Music]
delicious I am so impressed yeah this is
nice
this is good this struggle was so real
easily the hardest tasting video I've
ever made and certainly the longest I
don't know if I could have done it
without you for sure I think I probably
would've given up for all let's eat some
of that ice cream it's really good maybe
we have like 19 tubs of ice cream map
whoa what's goes to eat Mamma Mia - not
a plug
[Music]